بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد عليه افضل
الصلاه واتم التسليم سيد رئيس مجلس
السياده
الساده اعدام مجلس السياده
الساده في الاليه الثلاثيه الامم المتحده
الاتحاد الافريقي لايجاد
الساده في الاليه الرباعيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دوله الامارات المتحده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بريطانيا
الساده السفراء
ساده الاطراف المواقعه على الاتفاق
الاطاري
الساده غاده الممثلين الاجهزه النظاميه
الساده ممثله الاعلام اجهزه الاعلام
قسمحوا لي في البدايه نتقدم بالتحيه
والتهنئه
لجماهير شعبنا الكريم
بمناسبه حلول
شهر رمضان المبارك اعاده الله علينا
بالخير واليمن والبركات
والامن والاستقرار
التحيه لكل الحضور في هذه الورشه التي
تاتي تتويجا لمساعينا جاده للمضيء قدما في
الترتيبات اعاده بناء الدوله السودانيه
على اسس جديده
تلبي طموحات واشواق ابناء وبنات شعبنا
في النهضه والتقدم والازدهار
ان انقاذ هذه الورشه جاء في لحظه مواتيه
تمثل فرصه لكم لا فرصه لم يكن يتوقعها
كثير من الناس
ولذلك من فهمنا بان عمليه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري ليست مهمه سهله ليست مهمه سهله
لكنها ضروريه كجزء من الاصلاح من اصلاح
الدوله ولذلك فان الوصول للجيش الواحد
هدفنا جميعا
ونسير فيه بقناعه وفقا للمسائل الفنيه
المتفق عليها
[تصفيق]
من الحكمه من الحكمه ان نضع الاساس الاساس
لذلك على نوح التالي
اولا الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ليس نشاطا
سياسيا ولا يجب ان يخضع لاي اجنده سياسيه
فهو عمل وطني مرتبط بالاهداف العليا
للبلاد قبلناه برضا ووعي كاملين مستفيدين
من التجارب الانسانيه في محيطنا الافريقي
والعرب والعالم هناك الكثير من النماذج او
الامثله في عمليات الادماج الجيوش التي
تاتي غالبا في ظروف مختلفه عن الواقع
السوداني
كما هو الحال في تجارب جنوب افريقيا
والفلبين
وذمبابوي
وناميبيا وغيرها من البلدان يجب علينا
الاستفاده من هذه التجارب مع الاخذ في
الاعتبار والفوارغ الكبيره
بين جيوش تلك البلدان وحاله قوات الدعم
السريع الذي انشات وفق قانون نظم عملها
وحدد مهامها ثانيا تحتاج عمليه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري الى تطوير ومواكبه في
التشريعات والقوانين وهذه مهمه وهذه مهمه
مهمه مؤسسات مدنيه مثل وزاره العدل
والمجلس التشريعي ثالثا استناد استنادا
على الفقر السابقه لابد من الاصلاح
الاصلاح يشمل اجهزه الدوله كافه
انني من هذا المنبر وطالما شرعنا عمليا في
بحث ترتيبات الاصلاح الموضوع الامنيه
والعسكريه انادي بان يخرج هذا البلد من
السجال السياسي تماما فلا سبيل الضوضاء
الهتافات والشعارات في عمل في عمليه في
عمليه في عمليه فنيه معقده وحساسه غالبا
اجزائها يجب ان يعالج خلف غرف محكمه محكمه
الاغلاق
بلوغ النجاح في الاصلاح المنظومه الامنيه
والعسكريه مرتبط بالاهداف الساميه التي
نزع اليها والتي يجب ان تكون محي الاجماع
وطني وهي ترفيع وتعذيب الامن القومي
السريع ولا تزال ملتزمه التزاما ابتزاما
بالتزاما لا لبس فيه بالانحياز لخيار
التحول الديمقراطي الذي يضع السودان في
مساره صحيح
والشواهد في ذلك كثيره منذ ما قبل 11
ابريل برفضها قمع التظاهرات ثم انحياز
الخيار الجماهير مرورا بالمرحله
الانتقاليه
الاولى وما بعد 25 اكتوبر وصول الى مرحله
الاتفاق الايطالي الحالي
وسنظل متمسكين بهذا الخيار لن نجامل فيه
ولنتخلى عنه وهذا بمثابه اعلام مبكر
ورساله رساله ينبغي ان تدركها الحكومه
المستقبليه التي ستتولى زمام الامور في
البلاد ان التحول الديمقراطي هدف
استراتيجي لا حياه لا حياه عنه مهما كانت
الظروف
الحضور الكريم اعتقد
جازما ان المدخل الصحيح لاعاده بلادنا من
حاله التوهان السياسي والاقتصادي الذي
تعانيه هو الحل السياسي الذي نعمل عليه
بقوه من اجل توافق السودانيين على كلمه
سواء وان نستعيد صيغتنا في انفسنا كمدخل
اساسي للنهضه والتطور والنماء
نستطيع ان ننجز المهام الوطنيه بمهمه
واراده وطنيه في اقل وقت ممكن
اذا هزمنا الخلافات السياسيه الضيقه
فالفوز للجميع والنصر يحصد سماره جميع
السودانيين
هذه الورشه تمثل ختاما ختام ورش القضايا
العالقه التي تفضي الى الاتفاق السياسي
والنهائي وبالتالي نحتاج للتركيز على
الغايه الازمه لهذه العمليه السياسيه وهي
فتح طريق النهضه امام شعبنا ووطننا ورفع
المعاناه عن كاهل المواطنين وتوفير سبل
العيش الكريم له ان الشواهد المعطيات
العالميه الراهنه تمنح السودانيين مزايا
كبيره ان احسن ان احسن استغلال ان احسننا
استغلالها في الوقت المناسب وتشكيل هياكل
الفتى الانتقاليه هو منصه الانطلاق داخليا
وخارجيا لتعويض ما فات السودان منذ
الاستغلال
السيدات والساده لقد منحنا هذا الشعب
الصابر كثيرا من الفرص ويجب ان يشعر الان
بانه قادر على حصاد ما صبر عليه
ولحسن الحظ والازمات التي تمر بها بلادنا
بالامكان عبورها وبسرعه
ختاما اعيد التاكيد على ان تدشين هذه
الورشه يعني بدايه عمليه الاصلاح المنظومه
الامنيه والعسكريه ومن المهم مواصله
عمليات الاصلاح والهيكله لتشمل بقيه اجهزه
الدوله وهذا امر على الحكومه المدنيه
القادمه ان توليه اهتماما كبيرا على
السودانيين خاصه القاده من مختلف الكائنات
السياسيه والمدنيه تحديد الخطوات
والتنازلات التي يجب اتخاذها البلوغ الحل
السياسي النهائي متوافق تام يحقق
الاستقرار لبلادنا ويؤمن لشعبنا حياه
كريمه في وطن معافى شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الان الفريق الاول لنتابع معكم انطلاق
اعمال ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم عن كلمه رئيس
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله حضور جميعا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
وكل عام وانتم بخير
تحيه
للقائمين على امر هذه
الفعاليه ورشه الاصلاح الامن والعسكري
تحيه لكل الداعمين
لمسار الانتقال مسار التحول الديمقراطي
تحيه
لكل الشعب السوداني وهو ينظر الينا وينتظر
منا ان نخرج اليه بما يرتضيه وبما ينتظره
منا كقيادات اتت في ظروف معقده وظروف ليست
كسابقاتها في فترات الانتقال السابقه نحن
جميعا نؤكد اننا
مخطط ما التزمنا به منذ بدايه التغيير وما
التزمنا به منذ التشاور مع القوى السياسيه
في اننا لن نتردد ولن نتاخر في انفاذ
التزاماتنا ولم نقف حجر عصره في سبيل
الدوله السودانيه نحن نؤكد ان الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري عمليه طويله ومعقده ولا
يمكن تجاوزها
بسهوله ويسرى ايضا اؤكد ان هذه العمليه
العمليه سودانيه خالصه قام بها ووضع اسسها
السودانيين
وفي هذا المجال نؤكد ان شركائنا والداعمين
لنا لهم من التقدير والثناء انا
بالتاكيد
ساتحدث قليلا عن مفاهيم الاصلاح وعن ما
المقصود بالاصلاح لاننا نريد ان نؤكد ان
قواتنا المسلحه وقواتكم المسلحه
مرت بتجارب عديده منذ نشاتها وهي في العام
المقبل ربما تكمل او ستكمل المئه عام هذا
التاريخ الطويل مر بتقلبات في حاضر
السودان وفي ماضيه هذه التطلبات انعست على
اداء القوات المسلحه وعلى مشاركتها في
العمل السياسي ايضا هذه المشاركه التي
اريد بها استغلال القوات المسلحه لدعم
جهات سياسيه او لفرض ديكتاتوريات او
لمسانده حكومات شموليه نريد لهذا الامر ان
يتوقف نريد ان نبني قوات مسلحه قوات
ملتزمه بالمعايير
[تصفيق]
بالمعايير التي
ترتضيها الانظمه الديمقراطيه نحن مؤمنين
لان هذا الاصلاح يشمل عده اوجه نحنا اذا
نظرنا لحالتنا نحن في الجيش السوداني
هذا الجيش مر بتجارب يمكن انتقل فيها
الحكم ديمقراطي كان الرئيس او وزير الدفاع
يمثل احد القوه السياسيه ايضا كانت قياده
الجيش منعزله تماما عن العمل السياسي اذا
لدينا تجارب نستطيع ان نبني عليها وهذا
الامر ليس ببعيد عن القوات المسلحه سوى
الرده من فتره لاخرى للانظمه الشموليه
التي تعمل القوات المسلحه ضمن السياسيه
ايضا هذا الاصلاح المعياري او الاصلاح
التنفيذي يجب ان ننظر اليه نظره فاحصه انا
اتوقع من شركاء هذه الورشه ان يكونوا قد
انموا المام تام من قانون القوات المسلحه
بالعقيده العسكريه من اين تستنبط
بالاستراتيجيه القوميه الشامله بكثير من
الامور التي نحتاج ان نضع اللبنات الصحيحه
لكي نتمكن من وضع الاسس التي سنتشارك فيها
جميعا لبناء قوات مسلحه سودانيه مهنيه
بعيده كل البعد عن العمل السياسي تستطيع
او يوقل اليها فقط حمايه الدوله السودانيه
وحمايه امنها دون الزج بها في اي معترك
يخص العمل الداخلي او عمل الامن الداخلي
او المشاركه فيها اعمال داخليه ما لم تطلب
الحكومه التنفيذيه والحكومه المدنيه منها
نحن نريد ان نمكن لاي سلطه مدنيه قائمه
قادمه ان تكون القوات المسلحه تحت امرتها
لكن هذه السلطه المدنيه يجب ان تكون
منتخببه بامر الشعب حتى لا نزج مره اخرى
بالقوات المسلحه في اتون التنافس والصراع
السياسي نحن بنحييكم ونفتكر انه هذه فرصه
مواتيه لنضع جميعا اسس الاصلاح ليس فقط
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وانما جميع اجهزه
الدوله التي مات انفك انها هي بتكون جزء
من الاصلاح الامن العسكري خاصه الاجهزه
الشروطيه اجهزه العداله الاجهزه اللي
عندها علاقه بالقوات النظاميه نحن بفرصه
ايضا
من خلال نطلب من الممانعين او الذين لم
ينضموا الى هذه العمليه السياسيه بان ما
يطرح هنا هو طرح سوداني تشاركنا جميعا في
صياغته وما يطرح هنا انا متاكد انكم اذا
اطلعتم عليه لن تجدوا فيه الا ما يلبي
طموحات الشعب السوداني وهو يخدم اهداف
التغيير واهداف التحول الديمقراطي لذلك
الناس الموجودين ما زالوا خارج العمليه
السياسيه لانه يقول لهم تعالوا اقرب كلام
مكتوب وشوفوه اذا لقيتوه وما متوافق معاكم
اقعدوا مع الناس
لكن نحن سودانيين وطنيين مقتنعين بانه هذا
الامر اذا ما فيه مصلحه للدوله مصلحه
للبلد ومصلحه للمستقبله نمشي فيهم ولا
خطوه نحن برضه بناكد وبنقول له ان احنا
بنسمع انه هذه العمليه بيقودوها الاجانب
وهذه العمليه يقودوها ابدا هذه العمليه
بينقودها نحن كسودانيين ما في اي زول عنده
بها علاقه ولا في اي زول عنده بها دخل نحن
الكلام ده بنقوله لانه حس من هنا حنطلع
ونسمع الكلام ده نحن بناكد ان المزرعه دي
حقتنا نحن سويناها برانا وحنواصل فيها
برانا لغايه النهايه وحيقعدوا يناقشوها
السودانيين يستكملوا نقاشه فيها سودانيين
وحيطلعوا التوصيات بتاعتها السودانيين نحن
برضو فرصه انه نطلب من اخواننا عبد العزيز
الحلو وعبد الواحد محمد نور انه السودان
الان يمضي بقطع حسيسه لوضع اسس حقيقيه
لبناء دوله ديمقراطيه تلتزم بالمعايير
اللي كل زول داير يشوفه موجوده لمستقبل
اجيالنا ومستقبل بناتنا ومستقبل بنات
اولادنا لكم التحيه ولكم التقدير
ومناياتنا الص للقائمين على امر الورش ان
يستصحبوا معهم مطلوبات المرحله ومطلوبات
الانتقال وان يستصحب معهم تجاربنا السابقه
وان يضعوا نصب اعينهم ما نقف اليه الان
نحن الان وصلنا وين
واستصحاب تاريخنا واستصحاب التجارب في
الدول المجاوره لنا واستصحاب المعايير
التي وضعها او طلبها الاتحاد الافريقي
طلبته المتحده طلب الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى
نستطيع انه تكون عندنا قوات مسلحه موثوق
فيها وموثوق بها من قبل الشعب السوداني
ومن قبل الجميع تستطيع ان تدافع عن
السودان وتحميه وتفتديه وهذا ديدا هذه
القوات منذ نشاتها قبل اكثر من 100 عام
ونحن حنسير في نفس هذا الدرب درب حمايه
السودان وحمايه اهله وحمايه كل ما يمكن ان
يتمناه الشباب وشابات السودان نحن برضو
لفرصه نحن يمكن واحده من المسائل والناس
اللي بيتكلموا عنها انه الجيش ما نوع او
جندر نحن طرحنا في السنه الماضيه او السنه
قبلها انه نرحب باخواتنا في كليه الحربيه
نحن نرحب بانه ينضموا لنا كمقاتلين يزودوا
معانا عن هذا الوطن ويدافعوا عنه نحن صحيح
ما عندنا تجارب مختلطه لكن عندنا انفجار
في الجيش نحن الان عندنا حوالي 12% من
قوات المسلحه بالعنصر النسائي
عندنا منصه لتدريب النساء كليه حربيه لكن
في المستقبل نستطيع ان ندمج هذا الامر
بحيث يصبح التدريب موحد للجميع الكل
مطلوبات المدافع عن الوطن حق ليس حصرا على
الرجال وليس حصا حصرا على فئه معينه نحن
بنحييكم ان احنا بنرحب بكل ما يمكن ان
يصلح هذه المؤسسه وبنرحب بكل ما يمكن ان
يضعها في طريقها صحيح لكم التحيه ولكم
التقدير السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]